in a week when she admitted she has
struggled with the attention the cameras
were out for Megan she was at least
among friends attending the oneworld
Youth Summit an event she supported long
before she married Harry Ella Watson has
worked with her and thinks that she is
staying true to herself by talking about
how she's been treated by the press at
one young world she's always been
immensely professional but also very
authentic and I think if you are an
authentic person who's true to yourself
that's not going to change whatever role
that you're in but I loved seeing her on
the ground with all these projects that
are clearly very dear to her you do
wonder what the Queen thinks about it
all Megan may have wanted this evening
to be about these young leaders
[Music]
but her decision to tell a documentary
about how difficult life has been and
Prince Harry confirming the rumors were
rift with Prince William has provided
ample material for a tabloid press they
feel is making their life a misery being
in the spotlight may be difficult but
you also get the sense that Harry and
Megan are trying to make the most of the
fact they are currently the Royal
Family's most talked-about couple and
that's why we're seeing this constant
stream of engagements and outings
promoting the causes that matter to them
but the focus keeps being drawn away the
latest twist coming from a source close
to the couple telling an American TV
network Harry and Megan have
single-handedly modernized the monarchy
quite some statement for a couple who've
only been married 18 months and one that
is unlikely to do anything to settle
down this family drama
Rhiannon Mills Sky News in central
London
[Music]